喂喂喂
能听到吗
听到
好
看到
然后公司的自助性
你假如我现在是张开的状态
然后其实我也不需要对它做什么配置
我现在如果说点角法的闭合
闭环然后我再去动这个机器
其实它现在已经类似于自动算是西藏
然后我如果现在点机械运行
他其实已经可以带走他了
我现在再把夹板给张开
夹板张开之后
它相当于自动就松开这个杯子
如果说这时候再去运动这个机器人10．2
那这不是已经做好了吗
但是我感觉后面可能要有一个
就我们刚说的那个配置范围
设置范围
就是我可以给你看一下这边这个
你看一下这边有没有
你说就那天那个可编辑的那个
对
因为我们之前不是也有这个
对吧
应该就是一个3D可视化
再加上一个上下左右的一个控制和中心点的
有看到吗
它上面这些绿色的这些范围
就相当于是让用户可以去配这个检测这个范围
我们现在是相当于给他自己内置了一个比较算是比较正常的一个范围了
检测的范围
假如说用户觉得精确度不够的话
他可以去
比如说配这个
你去选中那个开
然后开那个艾特
您开通A图
对
就是他这边是可以这样
比如说调大调小这个范围就可以决定他现在这个盒子能检测到的范围
也就是说这个盒子跟这个绿框发生了交接是吧
碰撞
对
其实主要就是靠这个绿框的范围来检测物料的
然后比如说像用户我还能编辑这个
这个我听起来好奇怪
这用户编辑这个干嘛
因为需要开放他编辑这个的
因为有的时候我们预制的这个范围
它可能不符合用户那边的需求
包括说后面用户自己导入的那些模型
我们不可能说能通过计算的方式给它计算出来它这个夹爪究竟是怎么去夹的
所以说就是导入的模型需要用户自己去配置的
然后我们我们可以预制一些我们自己的模型的
但是再怎么样都导入的模型的用户也要自己配
所以说就应该全部都开放给用户
他可以去自由的去调整这些碰撞的范围
你你你比如说我我比如说我是我是作为客户的话
我我我怎么知道我要配配多多大多小
那你就是看你这个夹爪
你你你觉得你这个夹爪需要在多少的精度范围内能夹到那个物体吗
夹到那些物料
主要也是这个夹爪算是那种比较规则的
我们如果有一些不规则的那些夹爪
那可能就要动态的去调整那个范围
包括说有些比较精细的时候
你那我们这个预制的
他可能这个夹爪的夹区范围比较大
它有可能会夹到碰撞到其他的比较小的物料
这时候就要你精确的调整它的范围
去避免去夹到这些小的物料
假的小的物料
就是你比如说两个紧挨在一起的
夹什么物料
不是用户他可以自己选一下
但是这个假的这个范围是不是说一个物料出现在这个范围里面
可以被夹
对不对
你如果说你如果说要让用户去配
他要夹什么物料的话
那假如说这个机器人他要执行的任务很多的话
你相当于你就要配很多个物料了
那就退回到我们之前那个实施工作的那个面板
就要配去配一大堆的物料去让他去识别
你这样的话是对用户来说应该是成本是更高的
应该就是作为java这个功能
应该是比较通用的一个东西
它在这个范围内产生了碰撞
就应该被夹到
如果如果把这个范围调的非常大
就是调到两个都夹到中间交集的这样的情况的话
会发生什么事情会发生比如说我这个
对对对
比如说这个里面有很多问题
但是你如果是这样的话
你假如说我把这个当那个杯子
过了两天
对于
这个杯子应该没没啥问题
但是你如果那个那个时候扩到外面的话
应该就有问题了
外面
你假如我们现在就假设这个杯子
对吧
对对对假如你现在这个范围特别大
那你这个杯子只要一进来就会触碰到刚刚那个范围
假如说我们刚刚刚刚这个范围是很小的时候
杯子进来他就可能碰不到那个比较小的那个盒子
需要夹爪
比如说闭合闭好之后才能接触到
那就是不好意思
这个夹板的话你那个开的在哪
我们现在的是比较规整的
但是你这个夹爪如果是他的往外扩的话
就会出现在这个范围内在这个范围内的时候
这个物体也会被夹住
就是它不在夹爪里面
它在夹爪外面
但是因为这个比如说这个碰撞
体夹爪可以选择夹住
并且把它带走了
是不是
对
就是就会出现那种也可以算穿帮
他那个物料明明在甲长外面
但是被一块带走了
我觉得这个好像我想想好像感觉有问题
你这个木料
你让客户来去按照他是要讲什么
然后去调一个爪子的
他他不是说他不是说那个就是什么都能加的
是有一些物体我们给他加上那个物料的tag之后
他只会加取物料
不会夹取其他的东西
这个是有的
但是这个范围的绑定
按照我们之前的经验来说
这个是很有必要去让开放编辑
就是他要去自由的去编辑你这个夹取的范围到底有多大
就是大部分的情况我们会在在我们的甲板上配一个正常的识别范围
可以应对大部分的情况
但是比如说遇到比较少部分极端情况的时候
可能用户就需要自己去调整一下这个检测范围
然后让他不至于说去夹错那个物料
其实讲什么物料是不是还要用户再选一次的
这样就不需要选了
对
因为正常来说就是我们走的是仿真
你仿真的话
他走的那个程序就应该是在实际那个场景里面的程序
你如果去勾选物料的话
那就是相当于做一段假动画的那种效果
那种的话就没有起到仿真的应用的效果
如果说你要去配他要讲哪个物料的话
相当于你比如说你现在四楼这边
四楼这边它相当于不是有有很多这个点位
对吧
然后这不是点位
密码太大了
这些点位那你就是说你要在他每一个运动到某个地方的时候
他如果要加物料
你要在他每一个后面都要去设置
他每一条点位你都去设置
他要讲哪个物流
现在相当于完全不要这一套了
对就是只要这个夹子放到一个有有物料的这个位置
就是设定刚刚那个范围
然后就有一个夹取的这个动作
就可以把这个物料给带走
因为按我的理解是你比如说你那个真实的那个夹爪
他也不在乎
就是说你到底要夹什么
他只他在现实里面他也只是比如说他夹出来闭合了
那他有东西他就给他夹住了
对吧
没有东西的话
那就就是没有东西
对
我我我大概明白这个逻辑了
就是原来这套就完全不要了呗
就现在只是说给这些可以交互的
可以夹的这些夹子是一个范围
对
是一个
他那个检测范围类似
于是一个检测范围
加上一个是不是要讲
对
就是加上一个
比如说我检测到你的夹板是闭合的那我就会夹去
如果你夹子松开的那我就会执行那个松开的动作
把那个物料给松掉
这样的方案
是不是逻辑还是不大理解
就是这个这个夹子已经张到最开的这个状态了
然后我把它检测的范围是就是这个夹子夹
就是这个夹子本身它也是不是说完全能够两边捏到一起的
那他本身有个范围
它本身有个范围的
对它本身有个范围
为什么还要配置这个范围呢
不是你你夹子的范围是你实际那个实际它运动的范围
对吧
对他运动
你实际运动的范围跟我比如说我到底哪里能检测到物料的一个范围是两个东西
你理解我的意思吧
就是说我们检测物料是靠这个绿色的这个盒子的
假如说你物料进入到我们这个绿色的检测框里面
我才能识别到
而不是说靠你这个夹爪的运动去识别
而且夹爪应该也有形成了
有形成就行
对你能控制行程
那有的时候你的那个控行程设置比较小
他我们的包围盒如果设置的比较精确的话
你那个行程比较小
他就是没碰到
那不能夹起来
这也是很正常的一个逻辑
就是看你到底要精确的话
还是一个比较偏动画的一个效果
如果偏仿真一点的话
你就是设置的比较精确一点
这样的话你只有正确的形成
才能正确的假取物料
就是你假如说他他他就想做一个很粗糙的东西
你粗糙的能模拟一下
让他完全可以把这个放
比如说我配这么大对吧
那我只要这个夹子
随便进来一碰一下
这个杯子就可以给它夹住了
那你比如说你点位想要精确一点
那你这个东西比如说设置的比较精确
那你就得比如说刚好这个杯子刚好两边要夹爪闭合的时候
两边要一起合拢之后才能接触到这个杯子
这样才能夹得起来
所以我们设定的范围是两边闭合的时候刚好跟这个物体有有交接
主要是看具体使用的那个需求
就是你具体使用的需求的不一样的时候
他对于这个精确度的要求是不一样的
有些时候你只是为了做一些简单的话
我们预设的是比较精准的
他这个时候就是设置一些点位
他可能设置的时候到那个地方
因为我们设置的比较精确
他夹不起来
但是他不需要关心这个到底能不能夹起来
他只需要把这个动画做好就行
那这个时候他就可以把这个点位设置的比较大
这样的话就跟就是随便设置一个点位
就直接就夹起来了
关键是我我刚刚听了半天
我不知道用户能不能理解这个事情
就是我听了半天我就有点懵
如果是作为工程化的工程师来说
他是理解的
因为他本身就要去做这个仿真
我们觉得是之前那个太繁琐了
但是我觉得如果假设他不想
那么那个就是说稍微模拟的好轻松点
那就默认
就比如说我们给两个选项
一个是被精确的对吧
一个是模糊
我们叫模糊吗
模糊抓取
一个叫精确抓取对吧
就是如果是模糊抓取
那就像刚才说的
反正他到了我们就直接加
如果是精确抓取
你把那个勾上
那就得必须选这个
对吧
我觉得是这样的一个选项给他他会好一点
这样也可以
但是它模不模糊
其实主要是取决于它那个机械臂那个点位测的准不准
对吧
对
还有一个问题是说我的就是这个必须要做的原因是当用户自己导入模型的时候
这个时候我们没办法通过那个对计算去计算出来它到底你应该把那个包围这个碰撞盒设置到哪个位置
就这个东西我们我因为夹爪的这个形状都是千奇百怪的
我们没办法通过程序去自动去生成这个位置
所以说这个位置就需要用户自己去设置
那那这一套做完之后
你开放到那个普通的我们已经定义好的这个模型上
也是OK的
就是最最差最差我们需要在那个导入模型的那一步
需要去编辑这个操作
所以现在我明白
所以现在界面上要处理这个事情
就是加上现在这个绿框显示给一个给一种交互给他去调节
对
然后他是在什么时候再出现这个调节的
是在应该是你假如
说我点这个甲状
然后他可能会有一个类似于在右键上面
我感觉可能是放在右键上面
比如说有一个叫什么配置的功能还是啥的
就感知范围的
或者是他或者是放到这个夹爪的属性
放他那个属性里面也行
你点一下应该会开的
我们现在机器人这边是有试驾的
你假如说点到夹杂的话
就可以在夹角这边
比如说去让他配这个范围
这样的话是不是比较合理
然后就相当于打开了刚刚那个绿框的那个模式
然后它就调节这个盒子的大小
对
比如说他在这边有一个有一个比如说编辑他那个什么检测范围的一个选项
他点了开启之后
在场景里面我们就会比如说给他显示那个绿框的范围
然后让他去调
然后剩下的其他的都都不用做了是吧
还有一类传感器类型的
就是这种夹子类型的
都是这种处理方式
一套一套交付就行了
对
传感器应该是也是一致的
它都是什么
都是那一个开
的传感器的话
传感器我想想要不要让他让用户下
其实我们传感器它本质上就是一个从起点到终点的一条
类似于有一条射线
或者说对就是
一个射线
对一个射线的话
我们那个的话应该就是比较固定的
而且传感器这种也没必要让用户自己去导入模型
这种按照之前的逻辑来说
就是他们好像没有导入的
我们传感器都是固定的对
行
所以现在这个需求就已经收收拢到编辑这个夹爪的时候
给他一个调整这个盒子的交互就可以了
他他有两方面
一方面是3D的这个场景的一个创建
还有就是你看他这边是有这个界面的
他他通过这个方式可以去控制它的位置
我属性面板里面也是可以给具体坐标给他
但是其实这个盒子也能直接交互呗
对吧
这这个我理解
这个我
理解然后
收拢到这一步的话
相当于对用户的操作上就减少了很多了
他就不需要说我每机械臂设置一个点位
我就要去设置一下这个点位到底要找哪个物料
他如果程序多的话
他自己可能去翻都翻
不过来了
对而且不太直观
这个就是靠运行时自己的用那个物理去去判断它到底会不会加持
这样的话应该是按照我们之前的的经验的话
应该是比较OK的那
那那我提个问题
就是你这里也是放两个盒子
然后这两个盒子都有它的这个呃中心坐标跟这个世界坐标
对不对
那你光是这样去调
你没有一个物体的比对
你也不知道调多少吗
会不会
你是说物体的比对值是啥意思吗
就是没有一个假取物料的那个比对对对
没有那个物料
你你你不是也是空调吗
那你那你可以把物料拖到场景里面再去调
其实也是OK的
这个其实对
就是看你自己想怎么操作
对吧
也就是说打开这个调节的界面
其实不是进入这个设备的专门界面
它就还是在原来的场景里面的
他可以把夹子放到杯子那个地方去再调的
对不对
他也可以就是说他打开这个界面
它其实不影响场景里面
他还是在这个3D场景里面的
那他不需要进入一个新的界面
那如果是真的他调这个盒子的时候
他如果是接触到了另外一个物体
要给他做一些提示吗
你比如说你在调的时候
你接触到其他物体
它是不会有任何反应的
这个是只有在比如说你程序运行的时候
这个是我们自己控制的
就是不是说他碰到了
这个杯子
然后调的时候能实时检测到
我调到大概这样子就能
就像的话其实你可以做一个那个
你比如说你调了一个范围对吧
调一个范围之后
你可以比如在旁边点一下
比如那个叫什么预览
预览是否能加持到这个逻辑
然后你点一个叫做什么假的吸附的类似于
然后你点一下之后再动一下这个机械臂
假如说它能他能把这个再动一下这个夹子
他能把这个物料拿走的话
就代表他是能夹得住的
对吧
可是你点一下那个
你你你又没有安排他怎么拿走
他这个是怎么就不同的这个夹爪你是怎么怎么预览这个呢
就随便动一下把这个物料带走
还是本来他在脚本里面按照脚本去直接就往下跑了
都可以
你可以夹持住之后
然后通过那个拖拽视效或者是那个点动失效的方式
让他去动起来
或者说就是按照指定的方式
刚刚张工演示的那个单步执行
单步执行不就把那个杯子给他带走了
你比如说现在假如说现在就在这个里面
然后你现在想点了一个点了一个
比如叫什么
反正它属性这边
你有一个调
你调完之后
然后你比如说你想试一下这个范围能不能夹走
对吧
对夹走
然后我你可以在这边再点
再再放一个那个叫什么
反正我先暂时叫他
比如说吸附的按钮
那你点一下
点一下之后
然后你比如说你再去动这个
假如说你看到物料跟着动了
那不就是能检测到了吗
或者就是说我们可以搞一个预览的
就是你你点击我们测试一下是否夹持到了
然后我们把那些被夹持到的物料给它按照现在选中的逻辑给它高亮一下
这样的话应该也可以
就是不需要你再去点动了
对
客户我觉得必须要这个
对你比如说你有个测试按钮
你点一下测试
然后看到有物料高亮
那就代表他能查到
对
甚至我觉得退出在都不需要他他单独的去退出
而是这个预览的时候就自动给他做退出
预览完成回到这个编辑的界面
这样可以吗
你的意思是编辑的时候
就是碰到的时候就直接让那个被夹持的物料高亮
是吗
就是你不是调两个盒子的大小
我把它调调的差不多了之后
我应该有一个按钮
直接就帮我就是退出这个编辑模式
就正式的去预览一下
看能不能
这其实很简单
你可以比如说你按一下那个ESC或者你在啥的都可以直接退出
对吧
对
把那个模式给关掉
退出那个编辑的模式合适就行了
直接做到比如说快捷键上按一下ESC
这样的话不就很快吗
哦也行也行
行那就以这个就以这个夹子为这个标杆的原型
我感觉这个好像加起来很简单的
我对其实
没有什么太多
主要复杂还在我们这儿
对吧
对对对
我我我今天听下来这个问题好像被简单化了
是的
因为把之前那一套相当于给简化了
简化了一下
之前听起来我无从下手
这样的话就比较清晰了是吧
行
对这就很清晰了
然后再下来就是刚刚说的那个传感器类型的东西
就是比如说一个传感器的读数是有还是没有
或者是某种数值的
这个是影响到这个怎么调
它是不是也有一个这样的界面
传传感器传感器按我们之前做的是你传感器不是有一个一个发射的一个发射端
还有一个接收端
对吧
然后你比如说
什么传感器温度和红外什么之类
这算不算
也算
就比如说这种对我们来说应该都一样的
它只是表现形式不一样
因为他反馈到我们这边的结果就是他是否检测到了
我们不关心他背后的原理是什么
那他他就算是到我们现场的实际应用上
他也是反馈给我们到就一个信号是那个是检测到了还是没检测到了
我们程序里面也会把它简化成这种
就是到底有没有检测到就行了
所以检测到跟检测到是不是有一个
数一下说我现在就随便模拟一下
就比如说这两个球是那个发射端和接收端
对然后你假如说我有检测到东西的话
我看
如果说有检测到东西的话
我可以把这个
然后这边会他的发射端和接收端会有一条类似于比如说你叫他叫叫线也是也可以
我会把这个调细一点
让用户看起来的时候
他就像一条激光一样
然后你假如说你这个放在这儿
然后你有物料从这个中间通过
对吧
对
通过他如果检测到的时候
我可以让这条线变成红色
然后没检到时候变成绿色
这样的话我就可以他他就可以知道有没有检测到
但是这条线就是按照我们刚刚讨论的这样
这条线是不可以让去拖动它的长短了
这里这个其实它也不需要它拖动
因为就是一个发射端
到长短应该是要
你那个到底有多宽
这种应该是可以
就是可以可以设
就是说相当于你也可以把这个范围类似于开那个像家长那样的范围开给他去设置
那如果是其他某类数值
比如说是称重的或者什么之类
的没有限了称称重的话
称重的话
那用这种就不行了
对称重的话是另外的一套逻辑了
那个那个应该跟碰撞没啥太大关系
我们这边如果我们这边应该不太会涉及到重量这个东西
但是你如果真的要有的话
我们应​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌该就直接去读那个物料的那个属性了
我们不会说去真的去称他这个物料到底有多重
可能就是那个物料上自己带一个属性
就是告就他就多重就已经固定了
因为我们这边也没有没有没有说那种
你也没法知道他那个
比如说他在在我在模型里面到底是多重
那就这个属性
对你如果真的要做的话
也不是不能做
但是你那样的话
你让用户每一个物料都要去配它一个重量的话
那就有点太繁琐了
当然做也是能做
但是理论上来说没有这个必要性
行
那我现在理一下我这边做什么
我这边还还有还有其他的那个问题
你那个那个
就不是就是
他给我们的get那个界面
对
这​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌个可以
这边的就是我我现在是有一些问题
就是我之前不是在那个微信群里面有问这个边框
因为我们这边做我们unit这边做这种界面是没有那个网页端那么方便的
就像这种边缘的细线
我们不太去好做这个东西
如果你觉得很有必要的话
那就需要你那边去提供给我们一个对换
一种没有边框的
也可以有
就是你觉得可以能换的话
最好就是直接换掉
不能换的话就是你得把这个表做一张带圆角的边框的图给我
然后我去对这张图进行一个操作
就是你这边如果有那种无边框的方案的话是最好的
我们这边就不需要边框
这个阴影我们这边是有的
但是这个就是这些细线我们这边他这个引擎渲染这些比较细的东西会出现一些问题
最好不要用这种很细的线去做这些东西
行行
没问题
还有就是我这边在做的时候
发现有一些这些按钮的这个颜色它没有很统一
你是不是能给我们出一个比如说按钮用哪些颜色
然后哪哪些哪些UI用哪些颜色的这这种一个表格给我
这样的话我们去统一去调整它的表格
他的那个颜色表现会比较好
可以好
还有就是现在你这个界面上显示的时候
它不是这样的
但是我对于我们来说
我们应该不是这样的逻辑
我们上面之前不是有什么启动
启动仿真
重置的对
好像拿下来了几个
这个已经拿下来了网页端的吗
你的意思是拿下来
你要拿到我们那个三D仿真那个界面里面是吗
对对对
我们我们现在这边是是这个吗
我知道这个是之前的这个问题
我们之前讨论过
已经把它拿到动作面板跟仿真面板那里了
在刚刚的那个
那现在那个gate上是有那个对应的方案吗
现在好像没有
有的吧有的
是在在哪个地方呢
这个就是动作编辑这个面板
你把它放大一下哦啊
就是这里是吗
对对对
就是右上角的这个位置
对
说到什么群
对这右就是现在右上角的这一块就是真机
还有那个运行按钮
这可以控制
但是我们我们有些情况下我们是没有这个界面的
我们在没有绑定网页端的那个方案的时候
我们是没有这个界面
的那就你说没有动作编辑这个界面是吧
对
我们是有些时候是没有动作编辑这个界面的
我但是我的意思是说应该是把这个模式给它放到仿真那里去
一模一样的这样的就是甄姬跟仿真
让他自己去勾选一下
然后再点执行
其实我感觉像
你你你比如说像刚刚你看到的这一块
就是对这个东西他现在放在全局的话是有一点困惑的
之前聊过这个问题
而且现在这种切换tab的方式的话
也不是很直观
那我们的想法就是这个东西就是最差它它应该是放在我们现在这个标志性的这个界面里面
就应该像这个一样
对最差应该是我们这边有一套独立的
而不是我们必须要依赖他他的这个界面
因为我们有些我们在没有绑定这个场景的时候
我们是没有这两个界面的
这样的话因为我们我们这边后面预计也要去做自己去执行的逻辑
就不依赖这两个界面去执行的
但是执行的逻辑还是跟那边是一致的
对不对
它有单独仿真
然后单独真机
然后两边都一起
对对对
是的
我知道我知道
那我把它加到那个仿真这个界面的工具栏这里
就加到3D这边
对
还是上面
那个那个栏里面
那就是说对加的
工具要改一下
我觉得还是再加到工具栏那边会好点
就是最最顶部再加到这个工具栏
对
工具栏栏里面这样
然后这里有一个细节你们要注意
就是因为两边程序
你看现在右边程序其实也有这个功能
如果我到时候你们做的时候
比如说那边触发了
你这边要跟着动
就是相当于你要把消息发到那边去
张建应该知道
这个是同步那个状态了
对
要不然你不同步那个状态
他两边就不统一了
这应该没关系
相当于他这边
比如他这边点了之后
我们要接收要同步
对对对
他他其实现在也都是MQTT的
是的
所以你所以你对
所以你应该也是跟现在施工实现那个程序里面一样
就是说他两边应该
是有个现在施工这个是有一个MQCT
它里面是有个MCT的
他他也是在这边选的
在这边选博体还是
流程图啊啊啊对我觉得这里可能还是要有有这个选择
要不然的话他两边你就没法
因为有的是会这个地方还是要有一个选择的
因为那边程序可能有的用户他在那边编的
有的用户在这边编的
或者甚至是两边可能他都有
对那你就去问他了
知道吧
那就是说还那就这个界面可能也得设计一下了
对
但是可能不叫
名字上肯定不叫这种什么播放数据源这个对吧
你应该说是仿真程序的来源或者怎么样
就是得得转让
让让他选择是我们比如说用3D的
还是用blocked的
还是用流程图的
对
那就是员工那边这个界面可能也得稍微考虑一下
你说
那现在这个再说一下
就是这个数据源设定这个跟刚刚那个运行的是什么逻辑
这个就是你比如说你在点这个仿真对吧
对然后你你要你要让他确定他这个仿真的数据是来源于哪里
比如说他有可能是来源于我们3D的场景
然后也有可能是来源于那个block那边
我那我那边有好像有做了这个设定了
现在相当于在动作面板那里那你你打开那个get的那个那个
对他这里他这里其实已经是有对应了
对不对
现在你运行的就是block的
然后我切到仿真
切到那个流程图那里
就是流程图的
对
你还是在动作编辑那里的
还是在动作编辑那里
他是在左边那里切换
我靠
你那边
要全锁
3D仿真
对
把这个放大了
对我们切到那个流程图
应该是在左边左下角那里切左下角
对对对左左左左最最左边最左边
对
不是有个流程图的那个图标吗
这个是你们
对这个不是
这个不是切这个东西
是切他那个
是啊
是贴的
只不过他在那个
比如说他的账号上面打不开而已
是就是这个
贴意思是他他这边是是切这个
我可以用流程图的
但是他他不是说是设置数据源那边的东西
他只是切换一个
他只是切换一个显示
意思是你这边点仿真的时候
你需要让他确定他这个仿真数据来源是来源于下面的这个下面的那个look
还是来源这个动作流程
或者是他们就直接来到我们3D我
理解的应该没错
流程流程图的这个是一套程序
block里的是一套程序
然后我们现在在动作编辑器这一边
其实两边的运行是已经很明确要运行哪一个版本了
然后我们现在是说在仿真这里面运行的时候
要先让他选择是哪一个数据源的版本
对不对
对
那那我理解没错
这个就放到一样的
放把这个运行放在那边去了
我觉得放在那边了以后
你直接改成那种下拉选项就算了
就不要搞这种
他他这边他这边有一个问题
就是你假如说他选的是blocky
对吧
然后你blocky里面它区域可能有主区
然后可能还有其他区域
所以他的
但是你的主区域
你不就是当前看到的这个仿真
不就是已经选了主区域了吗
这个是主区域的概念吗
不是
是你点block里那里
它其实是可以创建多个区域的对
所以好像是有一个选择区域的
就是是去执行哪个区域里面的代码
应该是
所以这个一共要放几个下来
这里面一个多
选择两个就行了
上面那个勾选不要了
对不对
我觉得可以不需要
因为你就相当于每次运行之后都下拉一下也行
还是说默认
然后他选择完了以后
就就是用那种就是用那种打勾的形式
那就是说你相当于你打勾的话
其实他只要勾一种就好了
对吧
不需要勾很对勾重要
对我觉得不用勾很多种
在外地本身也不可能多个并行
是的
然后你假如说勾到了单选的
对不对
是上面对上面是单选
上面是没有问题的
然后单选完了以后
你右边那里
你展开了以后就让他勾选就行了
勾完了那你就再点那个大的右就去运行
那我觉得有点
类似
于什么
也有点类似于你现在腾讯的这个会议
你点那个静音
那个麦克风旁边不是有个小箭头吗
对然后你点开
然后你不是可以选吗
选完数据源
对
你可以选
选完了以后
但是你点静音的时候
你其实是直接点这个麦克风图表
但是我觉得这个应该是跟后面的两个
比如说他是运行的这个按钮
应该是放在一个小小面板里面的
就是这些东西它全部铺开的话
会不会有点多
首先它有一个单单选框
有有3个小时
这个怎么说下
那应该是类似于这种
对你去选一个对应的模式
然后他就默认是这个模式
然后你去选完之后再去配置这个模式里面
你就是你要用哪个去
按理说只有blow需要配置区域
其他的不需要
就只要点你选中block的时候
这里面才会去你去选要去用哪个模式
其他的模式你选中之后应该就直接关闭了
然后这里面就是你对应选中的对应模式
然后你现在点运行
它就按对应的模式运行了
对我觉得是这样的
它只有blocky
需要那个需要一个额外的下拉框
需要一个额外的界面去显示
就是你去控制你要用哪个区域
其他的你选中就是这一个下拉框
你选中完之后
它就是对应的模式了
你然后你再点上面那个就运行了
那不然就是你比如说我在这边选的
假如说中间这个是不问题
然后他右边还能把他区​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌域给展这个
展开过来
就是有点拍了一个二级
就是鼠标右键
那种对blocky的
再把它那个区域给识别到
识别到它这个右边来
然后右边再选一下它对应的区域
这样的话就能直接一次性做好了
老外你说的区域就是那个主主区域
跟他其他区域
对
这应该是只有block有那个东西了
我们这边不会有这个东西
对
行行
我知道了
就是把它加在这一条的最右边
我觉得这样的话
就不需要再开一个多余的面板
但是不需要开一个多余的面板
你也分成两个三个
如果你给的相当于它是个图集
这是一个逐级往下选的
我感觉这样有点重
一个单独的面板对我们来说也没啥太大问题的那如果
开单编码就那就不需要做这个了
我的意思是你你其他的你其他的
你在这边其他模式选中完之后就直接运行了
只有这个block你点完之后
你还需要筛选
里面其实就有一个下拉
没东西了
对
那他他其实就是一个下拉框
如果觉得一​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌个单独的面板太麻烦的话
那其实